hi I'm here and this talk is about
Network optimization algorithms in the
congest model which are also secure
against these dropper adversaries and
this is a joint 12 quizman of pattern Al
on your gif the distributed model that
we consider is a congest model where the
network is modeled as an undirected
graph with n vertices and initially
every vertex only has a local view of
the network so each vertex Only Knows
its incident edges then the computation
proceeds in synchronous rounds where we
also have bandwidth limitations that in
each round every vertex can send it more
slogan many bits on each one of the
incident edges and usually the main
complexity measure that we look at is
around complexity the number of rounds
it takes us to solve some problems
and now let's assume that there is some
even adversary that is eavesdropping to
some of the edges in My Graph so this
eavesdropper can now see all the
messages sent over these edges
Now using this information the adversary
might do some private or sensitive
information that I don't want it to
learn so the goal in this work was to
design algorithms in the congest model
that are on the one hand efficient in
terms of number of phones but also on
the other hand secure which in the high
level means it's adversary gains no
information and I will now Define
exactly and what this means
so we consider a passive adversary
called an Instagram that controls a
fixed set of f adversarial edges and
sees all the messages sent over them
and this adversary is computationally
unbounded it knows the graph topology
and also the algorithm that we execute
however it is oblivious to the input of
the vertices and also to their internal
randomness
and the security notion that we consider
is information theoretic and it means
that the East dropper is required to
learn nothing on the private input of
the vertices
and to be more concrete if we have some
algorithm a we say that it is f secure
if for every set of it most F
adversarial edges the messages seen by
the adversary and the input of the
vertices are independent random
variables
now in previous work secure distributed
algorithms have been mainly studied in a
complete graph in the cryptographic
community
as for General graphs Jane gave an
optimal algorithm using diameter many
rounds for the secure unicast problem
where we have some specific Source
vertex that wants to send a message to a
single Target vertex
in recent work we also gave a secure all
algorithm for broadcast well here we
have some Source vertex that wants to
send the message to all the other
vertices in the graph as for General
graph problems it was implicitly shown
in a previous work that we can actually
take any non-secure distributed
algorithm and compile it into an
equivalent secure algorithm well this
compiler Works in a round by round
Manner and this results in
multiplicative round overhead of D to
the power of f
so even for logarithmic many adversarial
edges the round overhead is at least
linear in the number of vertices
and what we did in this work is we
looked at secure algorithms for the
class of a global optimization problems
which has been highly studied in the
congest model
and one of the main optimization
problems that we looked at is the
minimum spinning see well the input is a
weight function defined on the graph
edges so the input of every vertex is
defined to be the weights of its
incident edges and the goal is to Output
a spanning tray of total minimum weight
wherein the distributed output format
will require that every vertex is going
to know which one of its incident edges
are included in the output spanning
so in order to obtain security for this
problem it is required that the
adversity gains no information on the
weights of the edges
so for this problem we gave an f-secure
randomized algorithm for graphs that
tell order if Edge connected with round
complexity that is approximately D plus
F square root and many rounds and this o
tilds a polylogarithmic factor is In N
so and the the security notion that we
gain here is statistical security
meaning that the algorithm is secure
with high probability
so at least four poly logarithmic many
adversarial edges this nearly we get
around complexities it nearly matches
the non-secure round complexity for this
problem
and this algorithm can also be extended
to solve other optimization problems
such as approximate minimum cut and
Pathways aggregation while Pathways
aggregation can actually be used to
solve many other classical optimization
problems
okay and one of the main tools that we
use in our algorithms is a general
compiler that takes any distributed
non-secure algorithm and converts it
into an equivalent secure algorithm well
we also are round overhead depends on a
parameter called Edge congestion and the
edge congestion of an algorithm is the
maximum number of messages sent over an
edge throughout the entire execution of
the algorithm
so what did we show we showed that if I
have a graph which is order F connected
I can take any around algorithm with
congestion C and convert it into an
equivalent if secure algorithm with
additive round overhead of approximately
D plus F square root c n plus CF many
ohms so intuitively if the algorithm has
low Edge conduction we get a additive
round overhead of approximately F square
root n and this is in contrast to the
previous known compiler which had
multiplicative round overhead of D to
the power of s
okay so I'll now give the high level
ideas of the congestion sensitive
compiler and then turn to talk about the
secure minimum spanning tree algorithm
so uh in our compiler we are given an
all-round algorithm a with congested
an equivalent algorithm that is also
f-secure meaning that it is secure
against F adversarial edges
so the main idea of our compiler that we
are going to broadcast sufficient many
random keys that are unknown to the
adversary this we can do using the
secure broadcast algorithm
and then in each round when V wants to
send some message M to enable you this
is going to
choose one of the random keys that we
broadcast saw it with the message and
send it over the edge then in order to
retrieve the original message M you can
saw what it received with the same
random key and get the message that we
sent
and our goal is going to be to minimize
the number of random kids that we need
to broadcast securely and we'll do this
in steps
so our starting point is a simple
solution where we simply broadcast a
random key for every round of the
algorithm and every Edge so in total we
broadcast n Square Times R many a keys
then in each round a v in order to send
the message M to enable you and create
the message using the corresponding key
and I would like to know that this
message that we sent might be empty
as for security because we encrypt its
message using a unique random key we get
that this algorithm is secure actually
with probability one
however this is quite expensive because
we need to broadcast approximately n
Square Times our many keys
okay so the first step we do in order to
reduce the number of keys is that we
recall that the number of adversarial
edges is at most f
and we are also going to use the fact
that the algorithm is going to be secure
as long as we use different keys to
encrypt messages sent over this F
adversarial edges
so what we can do is we are going to
broadcast F Square login many random
Keys per round so we broadcast
approximately F Square Times R keys in
total then in every round V is going to
pick some random key from this F Square
login a collection and use it in order
to encrypt as a corresponding message
that it wants to send
as for security from the birthday
Paradox we get that with high
probability indeed we use different keys
to encrypt messages sent over the F
adversarial edges and therefore the
algorithm is secure with high
probability
okay next in order to improve the
quadratic dependency on F in the next
step we actually broadcast only F log M
random Keys per round so we broadcast
approximately F times R keys in total
then in each round instead of picking a
single random key V is going to pick
approximately login random keys and user
excel in order to encrypt the message
as for a security
it holds that with high probability for
each adversarial Edge
we are going to use at least one unique
key in disk so in order to encrypt the
message sent over this Edge
so here again we get that the security
holds with high probability
until now what we did is we sent a set
of keys per round and we didn't use the
congestion parameter of the original
algorithm a
now just like to know that even if the
original algorithm had low congestion
meaning that the actual number of
messages sent over each Edge is small
the secure algorithm will need to send a
message on every Edge and in every round
and this is because if say we don't send
a message on some Edge in some round in
the secure algorithm this can already
leak information to the adversary that
this Edge was silent in this round in
the original
um
algorithm
okay so we are going to distinguish
between two type of messages that we
need to encrypt empty messages well we
didn't really want to send anything to
you in the original algorithm and real
messages and we'll deal with each type
in a different manner
okay so our algorithm starts with
broadcasting a collection of CF login
many random keys in total and this is
done using the secure broadcast
algorithm
then in round I where V wants to send
the message M to enable you
if this is the real message meaning it's
not empty first we is going to pair it
with login many zeros to indicate to you
that this is indeed a real message
then similar to what we did before we is
going to sample a login many random keys
from this full of random keys that we
broadcast and use their excel in order
to encrypt this message
on the other hand if m is an empty
message meaning we didn't really want to
send anything to you it is going to
Simply send a random string over this
Edge
then when you encrypt the message is
going to also receive a random string so
with high probability the decrypted
message is not going to start with login
menu and this will indicate to you that
this is an empty message and he can
ignore it
as for security first we show that both
the encryption of empty and real
messages are distributed uniformly and
therefore the adversary will not be able
to distinguish between these two type of
messages
then we also show that with high
probability each real message sent over
one of the F adversarial edges is
encrypted using at least one unique
random key Ki in vexo and therefore we
show that the security guarantee holds
with high probability
okay so I'll next turn to a describe is
a secure algorithm for computing a
minimum spanning tree
now we call that in the minimum spending
it's a problem we are giving a weight
function defined on the edges of the
graph and the goal is to construct a
spanning tree of total minimum weight
and the obtaining security for this
problem means that the ease dropper is
required to gain no information on the
weights of the edges
okay so I just like to a first note that
any a MST algorithm even in the
non-secure setting have Edge congestion
that is at least square root n
therefore if we apply our compiler just
as a black box on a some non-secure MST
algorithm we will have a round
complexity that is at least n to the
power of three over four even even for
constant number of adversarial edges and
this is too much for us and therefore we
are going to construct the secure
algorithm in a more white box manner
okay so similar to many of the
distributed and minimum spanning tree
algorithms our algorithm is also based
on the classical barofka algorithm which
in the high level grows a forest of
components using log and many iterations
where in each iteration we select an
outgoing edge with minimum weight for
each component and edit and these edges
to the forest while ignoring Cycles
then our secure MST algorithm is going
to contain two main phases in the first
phase what we do is we apply a variant
of barovkas algorithm for log and many
iterations and we do it securely using
our congestion sensitive compiler and
this results in a forest of what we call
Basic trees
such that on the one hand the diameter
of each tree is bounded by square root n
log n and therefore we can perform
aggregation inside these two is quite
efficiently and on the other hand each
three is efficiently large it contains
at least square root and many vertices
and you will see shortly why these two
properties are good for us
then in the second phase we start with
selecting an arbitrary leader with the
node by G star and we also sample a
collection of a approximately square
root and many random vertices we call
landmarks now because the size of each
basic Trace that we computed in the
previous phase is um at least square
root n we get that with high probability
each one of these basic trees is going
to contain at least one sampled landmark
as for security because these vertices
that we choose are chosen arbitrarily
their identity does not leak any
information to the adversary and we can
just choose them in an unsecure manner
then the phase proceeds in log and many
iteration where we grow components that
are contained in the minimum spanning
tree
okay so we start with the basic trees
that were computed in the previous phase
and we also keep the invariant that
every vertex is going to always know
which of its neighbors are a included in
the same component in this integration
then in each iteration I first every
Landmark is going to compute the minimum
weighted outgoing edge of its a
component that touches the basic tree a
TJ
and this can be done using simple
aggregation inside the basic tree and
recall that these basic trees have
diameter at most square root login so
this can be done quite efficiently and
because that aggregation has congestion
a constant so we can apply our congested
sensitive compiler and do this in a
secure manner
then in each Landmark is going to update
the leadership style with the minimum
weighted outgoing Edge that it shows and
this can be done using the secure
unicast algorithm of Jane
Now using this information g-star can
locally compute the minimum weight
outgoing edge of each component
and it's also construct the merges
component for the next iteration so it
constructs the component of a s i plus
one and this can be done locally by the
leader
now this style is going to update each
Landmark with the selected edges and the
new components
and this is again done using the secure
unicast algorithm of [ __ ]
now each Landmark is going to update the
vertices inside the corresponding basic
tree with the new edges and the new
components and this can be done using a
simple aggregation inside the basic
trees compiled with our congestion
sensitive compiler
okay so this was a high level idea of
our secure minimum spanning tree
algorithm so to sum things up in this
work we provide f-secure algorithm for a
collection of network optimization tasks
such as the minimum spanning tree
without complexity that is least at
least for a small f f that is poly
logarithmic nearly matches the
existential bounds of the non-secure
algorithms additionally we provide a
general compiler that transforms any
non-secure algorithm into a secure one
with round overhead that depends on the
edge congestion
okay so I'll stop here and thank you for
listening